[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you've been keeping up to
date with our Game of Thrones videos
then you'll no doubt be aware that
season eight of the show has been
getting some pretty let's say mixed
reactions to it nobody really seems that
happy with it including the actors so I
thought I'd put together a compilation
of all the clips we have so far of cast
members dropping just how disappointed
they are with season 8 this is full
spoilers ahead and know the actors don't
really drop anything major if you're not
fully caught up with the show you may
have some things room for you so I
highly recommend that you turn off now
if you haven't seen all the way up to
the latest episode without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's see these
hilarious Game of Thrones actor
reactions just between us
just between us yeah okay promise not to
not to put this on oh yeah I promise 60
minutes or anything how would you
describe it how does it in there's too
many elements that to be able to please
everyone where you're not gonna tell you
with complex a story with chatter it
ends brilliantly I don't know if what
people are expecting I don't know that
people are I think people some people
will be satisfied and others not so much
what I love about these is that everyone
is just kind of nervously laughing when
the Estella's going to end and they're
just kind of like um yeah I think the
cast did know that lots of people are
going to be disappointed and they're
just trying their best to prepare
everyone for it next up is Emilia Clarke
and we've got quite a lot of clips from
her now what I love about her is that
she's such a sweet person she can't even
lie so whenever she's asked about it she
gives like some sarcastic answer
how it's going to be the best season
ever I can't really do it justice so
let's just cut to that have you shot
your final scenes yet and are you happy
with how things ended the Sheena's
filmed her final scene for the final
season of the series and she feels some
kind of way it's me up knowing that it's
going to be a lasting flavor in
everyone's mouth of what Daenerys is so
I dredge this scripts this season and I
in some kind of a daze walked out of my
house the only thing I check was my keys
and about three hours later I arrived
back home and I still hadn't taken it
all in are we ready
this is I mean I don't know I don't know
if anyone's ready I don't know if TV's
now it's clear that Dany has just went
full-blown genocide 'el maniac in like
the last two episodes which is massively
annoyed fans who want to see some earn
character development from her so I feel
like Emilia Clarke is aware of this and
knows just how breakneck it is the next
couple of Clips I'll just let them roll
because they're absolutely hilarious and
they just kind of show how much everyone
who was in on the scripts knew that it
was gonna annoy people
so take it away it takes
to a place that you never saw coming
that I didn't see coming yeah be
prepared it's fun to drive if you could
describe the season finale of Game of
Thrones in one word how would you
disappoint you can be important without
necessarily doing well as people say are
we going to be happy with the ending
maybe not we've never bothered about
keeping people happy before you're going
to be satisfied but happy is something
that we don't specialize in I'm afraid
were you happy with how it ends that's a
very good question
I was I was sort of you know it's weird
walking around with this I think for all
of us walking around with this big kind
of secret we know how it all kind of
wraps up you know and I don't think
anyone should really it's like when you
finish a book like you're not happy it's
over I you're not you don't finish a
good book and go I'm happy I finished
that yeah sometimes you are if it's an
amazing nd if it turns out as you like
and you go now that is an ending that's
amazing you have this grief that you
have grief that's exactly the same with
this nine years of doing this show and
no matter how it ended or how it does
end you know there was there's always
gonna be a bit of you that goes odd you
know there's this kind of loss around it
so maybe not happy but very satisfied
very sad
hopefully it will change TV again like
it like it did originally and and break
boundaries I think it might I want to
talk about Game of Thrones for a second
and her fans who are watching around the
world what do you I know you can't tell
me anything about it but what do you
think the reaction will be to the final
episode and shocked shocked with the
Greg that's I think that's breaking news
shocked all right now
not not enthusiastic not pleased but
shocked I just think there's gonna be a
lot of it's it's going to be huge that
much everyone needs to know it's took us
a very long time to shoot this one for a
very good reason but I think there's
gonna be some things in this that I know
there's gonna be some things in this our
season that will shock people there you
go people that's exciting I'm going to
ask you a question it's coming closest
okay no none of it
the facial expressions fans will have
when they see the final episode Oh
like like I I just think it's gonna be a
full some people will be like and some
will be like and someone to be like a he
something it'll just be screaming and
some people will be crying and who's
that your reaction when you saw the
final of the script yeah it was almost
like I had every single emotion someone
could have and their nature and then it
went like a vacuum like it went and then
I just walked out and I kinda know
you're not allowed to say about the
ending Game of Thrones
maybe try something different could you
give us your into the camera your facial
expressions what it was like reading the
last episode for the first time what it
was like the different stages you went
through I mean it's pretty much one
stage okay just that's it so without
giving anything away
yes when you read that final script yeah
what happens to Daenerys yeah what was
your reaction it's it's it's um it's
sort of almost impossible to answer that
question without giving something I
I have so much to say that's me being
very honest
it was pretty surprising
so like I've had theories all along and
all of them were wrong I was very
shocked and surprised at certain events
unfolding and then I then I blood my
eyes out I cried I think it's very big
and very shocking yeah um are you guys
ok with the ending personally did it end
the way you wanted it to end season see
ok is a typical choice of words we have
this thing about the if you wrap this
show up in a pretty pink ribbon and go
oh they're gonna be happy and that's
gonna happen and they're gonna be blah
blah blah people look at it and go
you've just treated us as adults and
grownups for the last eight we have
thrown stuff in her face now we've had
difficulty dealing with if we wrap this
all up in a ribbon you'll hate us for
the rest of our lives so this is theirs
this is like life there's nice stuff
underneath it so nice stuff you'll have
to wait see pull halfway through season
one okay we got a question do you want
Ned Stark to die in Episode nine that
have done absolutely not no way do you
want the red wedding to happen of course
we don't we love these characters we
want to keep them around we've never
given people what they think they want
because because we know that people
really like to be challenged and they
don't like to be spoon-fed and all of
those great moments those visceral
moments of people's reaction to this
show have come from things happening
that they didn't want to happen if we
come around and present the end of this
show with a nice pink ribbon on it and
go there you got everything you wanted
people would just showed you patronizing
I mean I just I've never seen anything
like this when people are trying to
promote a season and you could just tell
they know how bad it is I mean like I've
sat for the past eight seasons dry of
Satya wondering how Cersei would die who
would kill her you know who was gonna
get the big bad villain and in the end
it turned out it was just a pile of
rocks falling on her like the same with
the night king as well I know
had that bit about area and this just
wasn't intelligently done and even the
creator's new air and it just feels so
badly handled and you know I can't kind
of like about it it's hilarious watching
these reactions I just wanted it all in
a nice pink ribbon I guess which we're
not getting so all in all what I took
from this is that it will be shocking
yes very very shocking shockingly bad I
guess best season ever
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these reactions whether you
still enjoying season a or if it's done
for you comment below and let me know
and I just want to give a huge thank you
a Red Boy for putting together the
majority of these clips I've linked
their channel in the description below
so definitely check them out for more if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my full
plot league breakdown for the final
episode which would be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who are
never miss in television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]